one of the busiest 24 hours of news in a
long time so let's get right into it we
had Democratic presidential debate
number seven last night and it was the
most shameful one so far in terms of the
hosting and the anchoring done yesterday
by CNN of course as you probably now
know CNN on Monday published this
exclusive report about how Bernie
Sanders in 2018 supposedly told
Elizabeth Warren that a woman can't win
the presidency and then there was the
pretext of that used to create drama
during the debate exactly as I predicted
would be done and in general we'll get
to that but in general
CNN filled the debate with baiting
questions and split screens trying to
get people to fight basically nobody
took the bait and that was actually a
good decision by the candidates they
wasted time with these open-ended
questions like what makes you qualified
to be president which at this late stage
of the game just weeks before the first
votes are lame worthless Wes waste of
time questions
CNN wrote follow-up questions in advance
which makes sense to have but the
questions ignored the candidates actual
answers so the debate was filled with
follow-up questions from CNN that were
complete non sequiturs completely
ignoring what the candidates were
actually saying really embarrassing and
the biggest example of this was when
they asked Bernie about when he
supposedly told Elizabeth Warren a woman
couldn't win
Bernie denied it and they go right to
Elizabeth Warren saying how did you feel
when Bernie said a woman couldn't win
Bernie just denied it and they skip over
asking Elizabeth Warren well Bernie
denies it can you clarify are you sure
he said it was their context nothing
look at this embarrassing moment from
yesterday's debate
CNN reported yesterday that and senator
Sanders senator Warren confirmed in a
statement that in 2018 you told her that
you did not believe that a woman could
win the election why did you say that
well as a matter of fact I didn't say
oh and I don't want to waste a whole lot
of time on this because this is what
Donald Trump and maybe some of the media
want anybody knows me knows that it's
incomprehensible that I would think that
a woman could not be President of the
United States go to youtube today
there's a video of that
of me 30 years ago talking about how a
woman could become president of the
United States in 2015 I deferred in fact
the senator warned there was a movement
to draft Senator Warren to run for
president and you know what I said stay
back senator Warren decided not to run
an IV I did run afterwards Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by three
million votes how could anybody in a
million years not believe that a woman
could become president of the United
States and let me be very clear if any
of the women on this stage or any of the
men on this stage win the nomination I
hope that's not the case I hope it's me
but if they do I will do everything in
my power to make sure that they are
elected in order to defeat the most
dangerous president in the history of
our country so senator Sanders senator
Sanders I do want to be clear here
you're saying that you never told
senator Warren that a woman could not
win the election so to screw senator
Warren what did you think when senator
Sanders told you a woman could not win
the election
I disagreed Bernie says I didn't say it
next question is hey Elizabeth what did
you think of what did you think of
Bernie saying that this is not how you
run a debate and then afterwards they
premise a full question round on it
going to other people with the title on
screen saying what do you say to people
who think a woman can't win the election
it's like who nobody has admitted to
saying that Bernie just denied having
said that it was almost a Saturday Night
Live parody of what a debate would look
like but unfortunately it was the actual
debate now by the way not to Pat myself
on the back but word for word I called
how this would go down two days ago I
tweeted on Monday prediction when it
comes up tomorrow Warren will refer to
Bernie as her friend and Bernie will say
of course a woman can be president but
the moderators will keep going check out
what Elizabeth Warren said I disagreed
Bernie is my friend and I am NOT here to
try to fight with Bernie and then Bernie
Sanders later getting the opportunity to
clarify and literally use the words I
tweeted on Monday of course a woman can
be President this is no big pat on my
back it's that obvious how it would go
and with what CNN would try to do with
it we could anticipate how Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders would handle
it now on policy there were some
interesting moments the candidates were
asked would you bring all troops home
from the Middle East
no one said yes and this tricked some
people Elizabeth Warren said she would
bring all combat troops home that's
playing coy with combat versus
peacekeeping okay and you have to
understand that when I tweeted about
this last night a few people wrote back
and said no Warren said she would bring
everybody home no she said she would get
combat troops out of the region that is
a way of not really answering the
question Bernie Sanders for example a
lot of people thought no he said he
would bring them all home Bernie Sanders
listed things that we would be better
off having troops do than be in the
Middle East but Bernie also didn't say
that they would all come come home and
this is
actually not shocking it would be
unrealistic for a presidential candidate
who understands anything about
geopolitics to say every troop is coming
home from the Middle East because the
reality is some troops are going to stay
in some places in the Middle East
whether Bernie's president whether
Warren's president whether Biden's
president or whether Trump is reelected
president that's just being realistic
but if you listen to how they said it
none of them said they're all coming
home there was a discussion about health
care costs Bernie was asked about the
price of his plan and he was asked
multiple times don't we deserve to hear
the price tag
Bernie has given us the price tag and
now you can argue Bernie's price tag is
wrong if you want to that's a legitimate
conversation to have but to continue to
pretend that Bernie has never addressed
the cost of his plan again more of this
staging by CNN which we'll have more
about tomorrow
that was adversarial to Bernie to say
the least they also focused on the cost
of health care without ever mentioning
the cost of wars or military
interventions which is very typical in
these sort of establishment debates when
it comes to foreign policy Pete Budaj
edge didn't have a particularly good
night often his answers were very
consultant like in a way he would state
what the problem is in society or in the
economy and say that we must fix it and
then his time was up that those aren't
solutions it's not policy to restate
what the problem is it's great that he
understands the problem he sounded good
doing it in his polished way but not a
particularly good night for Pete Budaj
the topic of free college came up again
and once again Budaj edge repeating this
thing about I don't want the children of
rich people to go to school for free
this is the wrong position if you have a
system where everybody pays in on the
basis of their income in order to fund a
tuition free state schools if the rich
are paying in their kids should be able
to get it otherwise the rich will start
arguing we shouldn't have to pay into
something that we can't benefit from
remember most of them are going to go to
private schools anyway mayor Pete is
just wrong on this let them get their
free tuition
to a state school if they want to go
because they paid in it's a policy
disagreement and I think he's flat wrong
on it
lastly Tom Steyer actually didn't do bad
billionaire Tom Styer bought his way
into the debates I don't support him I
don't think we need another billionaire
president I don't plan to vote for Tom
Styer but yesterday he actually did okay
he brought up climate change a couple of
times when it went well
here's one clip of Tom Steyer this white
climate is my number one priority and
I'm still shocked that I'm the only
person on this stage who will say this I
would declare a state of emergency on
day one on climate I would I would do it
from the standpoint of environmental
justice and make sure we go to the black
and brown communities where you can't
breathe the air or drink the water that
comes out of the tap safely but I also
know this we're gonna create millions of
good-paying Union jobs across this
country it's gonna be the biggest job
program in American history so I know we
have to do it I know we can do it and I
know that we can do it in a way that
makes us healthier that makes us better
paid and is more just stired did better
than Pete Budaj edge he did better than
Amy Klobuchar and in fact he did better
than Joe Biden as well who was
extraordinarily low-energy yesterday and
Biden probably benefited from not
getting as much speaking time if I
recall as Elizabeth Warren and as Bernie
Sanders so who won the debate if you
evaluate yesterday's debate from the
perspective of the average person I
believe this was a de facto win for
Biden this doesn't mean Biden did
anything great remember the more Biden
talks the worse it is for him but CNN
did what we knew they would do they
successfully pulled Warren and Bernie
into the story about whether or not
Bernie said a woman can't win they did
an entire round of questions about it on
policy Warren did fine Bernie did fine
there was nothing new or surprising
about the policies they were advocating
for they've been doing it for six prior
debates to yesterday seventh debate but
low-energy Biden was able as I predicted
to just talk about policy and even
though he kind of bumbled through it it
frames him as presidential and the net
effect yesterday with Amy Klobuchar
being an on fact
Tom Steyer basically a non-factor Buddha
judge certainly didn't do anything to
claw his way back into this thing the de
facto result is Biden gets another
couple weeks now where he remains the
front-runner with no major obvious
blunder despite just not sounding good
at all that is going to pull him out of
first place I know that to you and I we
watch this stuff closely Biden seems
slow confused at times centrist policies
that don't appeal to me but if you think
about this through the average voters
eyes the muddled Bernie versus Warren
thing is not going to take Biden out of
first place in fact it's going to
perpetuate it and that was exactly the
goal of the Bernie smear that started on
Monday so overall a completely botched
debate following the predictable CNN
playbook to a tee tell me where I'm
wrong check out some of the things I was
tweeting as the debate was going on last
night at D Pakman and tell me where you
disagree